what is going on reject nation its Greg
Alba here and it's John Humphrey over
here so today we're finally gonna review
the movie that everyone's been so
anticipating Blade Runner 20 49 oh boy
but before we go into our review we
wanted to give a quick shout out to
start us start or partnering up with us
on this review and several of our
upcoming movie reviews actually so we
discussed star dust in our Gerald's game
review but in case you missed that star
dust as a new social network that allows
you to record your own reactions and
share them with your friends
that's right Sir John you can record up
to 30 seconds of video on any film TV
show or even a trailer and we are really
loving using this app actually we're
really enjoying it so if you're a
cinephile you love movies TV basically
anything we talk about on this channel
then you're probably gonna love star
dust as well this app allows you to keep
track of all your favorites set up watch
lists and there's even a way to mark
your reactions for spoilers because
consideration is a nice thing yeah I
wish I wish there was a way we could
have done that for YouTube before Blade
Runner
yeah and as part of our partnership with
Star does if you send us your reaction
in the week leading up to a certain
movie will let you know which one you'll
have a chance to have your reaction
featured in one of our upcoming reviews
which is pretty cool so when you guys
download the app make sure to follow us
first so they know we sent you and we
put out the call make sure to send it to
us via social media tag us at the real
rejects as well as a Stardust app so you
have a chance to be chosen and now
without further ado let's take a look at
a few of those reactions before we hop
into this laid runner 2049 made the
impossible possible if you guys ever
watched a movie and just been so
emotionally overwhelmed with the just
everything about it the visuals the
acting that just it was just so good and
this is a visually stunning movie I mean
it is beautiful and breathtaking
you don't really need to see the
original it builds this entire world
beyond what we saw in the first Blade
Runner but it feels familiar to feel the
right level Ryan Gosling is fantastic in
this movie Harrison Ford's great this
was amazing we're the best of the year
please go see it uh it's square five out
of five you'll see it quick it's great
I got me it got me so good all right
Blade Runner 2049 finally here Lee here
there's so much to talk about there's so
many more there's so much to talk about
here you know from everything from the
directing the writing the cinematography
to the entire cast the score the sound
is uh it's all fantastic and precision
of heart memory the power now yeah
there's a quick review in a summer you
can just click off right now and not
hear any details about it there's a
quick review before going into this I
just want to say that our experiences
were slightly affected mine
significantly more than his we did a
live stream before watching this movie
that did affect my viewing experience of
the film because I started a live stream
sometimes we just do live streams on the
way to like an event or a movie some
might say this is my fault because of
the way YouTube is and maybe I should
have been more aware of it well maybe
you should or maybe there should be some
nicer subscribers who aren't such dicks
about things I'm like major plot stuff
was just spoil for me by like two to
three people knowing certain things that
unfold it does affect some viewing
experience your being out for it the
whole time but that's in a weird way
that also shows the strength of this
film because I still managed to be very
engaged despite knowing the outcome of a
lot of the mystery elements to this film
cuz I didn't know plot or anything going
into this film all I knew it was like
Harrison Ford might show up a little bit
late into the film that's about as far
as I knew watching this film we saw it
on IMAX thank God it was in 2d first off
I'm so happy it was in two days I'll be
honest with you guys I don't really
enjoy the first Blade Runner movie I've
seen it maybe three times now in the
past two months I've seen it twice I
think like it's really thought-provoking
and certain areas when
ponder it but I think in terms a plot
and characters I don't find it all that
intriguing or all that exciting I got to
tell you guys I did not walk away from
this film feeling that I thought yes
it's thought-provoking and enhances all
the themes it gets more messages in
there at the same time though its plot
its characters its overall storytelling
I was very engaged some it was like two
almost three hours long it's like right
there for TV yeah I didn't really feel
the length and I know you felt it a lot
more I felt the length most of the time
really I don't think it's a bad thing I
wasn't sitting there going this mood
yeah but I was like this movie takes its
time it really doesn't that's the way
didn't he likes to make his movies too
that's the way the original one is
because I'm I'm sort of with you it's
like that's having seen the first Blade
Runner a couple times now I appreciate
it more than I actually like loved it or
oral yeah fond leave that we're only way
more on the I appreciate side yeah
that's like I get why some people love
this and the designs are amazing the
ideas are really cool it I even like
Harrison Ford design this movie does
carry some of that pacing over I think
everyone can agree on with this film is
the visuals are absolutely dynamite
totally you know the of course they're
gonna infuse CGI more into this sequel
because thirty years later after the
originals the CGI looks great and the
visual effects is awesome and they
enhance the future setting they do some
things with the future that we haven't
seen done before even like little things
like certain characters eat food yeah
you know there are a lot of great little
details about what life is like how the
world works and those are some of the
nicest yeah things because there's so
much attention to detail in the
lifestyle of how people live in the
future
it feels lived-in it really feels like
we got to do more world exploration
that's and that's another credit to this
home you you definitely go a lot further
than LA it's very intriguing throughout
and the cinematography is the other
thing I think we all can agree on with
this film yes sir visuals in the
production design and the lighting that
is reminiscent of the original Blade
Runner but it does it's Roger Deakins
man no I do Deeks dude can't go wrong
with the deeps
oh yeah no I mean it's anime
we shot and Louisville - it really makes
you appreciate lighting yes there are
some immensely striking things where
scenes are lit all through shots so
you'll have these really stark ratios at
play you'll have these rooms that are
all living through the reflection of
water yeah they're amazing to look at
and some scenes like people aren't just
lit head-on like normal yeah a couple
scenes where people were mostly lit from
behind and that really brings up the
quality of the Fatah it makes it a much
easier film to be engaged upon because
of the visual aspect of visual designs
CGI and cinematography because this film
is pretty slow in terms of what we're
used to I don't think it's slower than
the first film it still generally takes
its time to feel like the Blade Runner
universe if we want to call it yeah it
is it is one that takes its time yeah
yeah and because of the visual aesthetic
it makes it much easier to hop on board
for a film that's nearly three hours
long yeah when both of these movies have
the benefit and especially the new one
has the benefit of you know even though
there is enhanced CG and stuff like that
there are also a lot of sets props and
and vehicles and things that at least
look like they were actually there and
act like they bothered to build this
really looks like a strong combination
of practical effects and visual effects
and it's all mesh super well enough love
feels we love to go into more details
about other things where I'm like why
they would give away because there are
some visual moments in this film that
some stuff deals with sexuality and that
like I don't want to give it away but
when it's there you're like this is a
really impressive visual scene yeah yeah
I didn't expect that and that's one of
the things that I do feel quite happy
about when it comes to this movie is
looking at the trailer there there are
some things that are deceptively
revealing there's so many other
surprises that I just wasn't expecting
to be exploring in this movie and that's
one of those things yeah there are a
number of moments that are both
conceptually interesting but also
visually a way they realize them is
pretty fascinating too and I do
appreciate how this film really is its
own thing but it is a continuation of
where we left off with the last Blade
Runner the world's grown it's changed
our point of views towards what
replicants re you get even more of that
in this film it's not just talked about
through a few characters you get to see
how society in general perceives blade
runner's perceives replicants and it's
it's fascinating the one thing that I
really noticed myself loving during this
movie was the score the scores I look at
the music score is fantastic when we
rewatched Blade Runner a couple days ago
I found myself looking up and going oh I
forgot how much I liked the music yeah
and that music is is different in a way
but you know they are familiar they are
building on top of it because it's not
that same like saxophone esque synth
line but there are a lot of very
striking droning foreboding synth sounds
and so and the sound design especially
if you go watch this in imax with the
IMAX sound it is just K yeah it does
really so you're gonna being loud it's
just really engrossing sound effects it
brings every little aspect of it even
more to life when the IMAX enhancement
for the for the actual scope of the
screen I thought was really nice - yeah
I mean it's not the entirety of the
screen but it was noticeably bigger and
crisper you know then a lot of
transcriptions I've seen and I gotta say
in terms of the directing of this movie
Denis did exactly what he said he was
setting out to do honoring the original
making it a continuation but also doing
his best to make it his own thing this
really does feel like it's more of Denis
film than him trying to make Blade
Runner again yeah yeah this feels like
another director's vision you know not
just oh we're doing more blade yeah yeah
it's definitely strongly linked to the
first one at the same time though its
main plot is very separate can't give
anything away yeah yeah the thing is you
gotta kind of dance around because it is
in a way a detective story as the first
one sort of is it's still a mystery tale
yeah and with that all the plot points
are important pieces of the puzzle
practic yeah yeah yeah it's a mystery
tale and it is an investigation story a
big difference I found with this one as
compared to the first one was I was
genuinely intrigued by the setup of what
this investigation is Ryan Gosling's
character Kay
to go on the cast is fantastic in this
film one thing that I'm sure I'll get a
lot of crap for saying is I don't really
care for Deckard in the first Blade
Runner movie I felt for like the main
character I just didn't really find them
all that interesting here yeah you just
really can't reveal anything when it
comes to Ryan Gosling's character a
setup of who his character is I found
intriguing I remember like right when
they were feel it I was like yeah the
nature of that character surprised me
sort of right off the bat now yeah
another thing I was like oh cool you
didn't give that up in the trailer yeah
we can't really reveal much he does a
lot of what we love about Ryan Gosling
oh yeah that was a mile stairs yeah walk
slowly made a lot of staring emotionally
more of an empty fella in search of you
know like having a want to have that
whole wanting to feel whole you know
things arrival the coverage its
placement on the vines gonna playing
lonely dude I was like okay yeah that
when you start seeing whose characters
really yeah he's perfectly cast this is
this is typecast right here yeah it was
great it he's fantastic added this
subtle build of emotions that are
brewing on the inside that he doesn't
know how to express as a big part of a
lot of Ryan Gosling characters and I
think he does an amazing job here with
it and I was definitely way more
connected with his character than I ever
was with Deckard in the first Blade
Runner we get emotionally curious about
his character Jared Leto it's kind of
funny because his huge deal how he was
in Suicide Squad he's barely in the
movie it's similar in the in that
particular sense here the better version
is a much better version of that because
when Jared Leto's there he's really damn
good yes a great character actor yeah
he's barely in the movie but when he's
there he serves a purpose same thing
with like characters like dave bautista
he's barely in the film as well but when
he's on screen is really utilized well
they're not a throwaway carry I feel
like didn't he's really good at casting
and making sure if you get a big actor
or a known actor they at least serve a
strong resonating for performance a
brave their their mojo it's not about
quantity to screen time it really is
about quality of the screen time that
they have there that's something that
shines in this movie in a lot of places
because there
there's more than one character like
that where they're not necessarily in a
ton of the movie but when they are
you're locked on them yeah good that
you're here you know you're distinct
Ryan Gosling plays a cop Robin Wright
plays the head and she's like the head
to the LAPD of one of those positions I
don't know she's a lieutenant to the
lieutenant
she's really good in the film because
she gets a chance to also be
multi-layered she's a character here
where she gets to showcase yet again a
strong female character with a layer of
a lot of humanity underneath as well
she's a multi-layered character not a
whole lot of screen time but when she's
there she really serves as strong
presence on the screen and she has some
pretty damn good scenes of Ryan Gosling
yeah I liked her performance a lot in
this and I was surprised I didn't really
think much of her presence in the
trailer but as a part of the movie I
liked there back and forth alive yeah
this is actress in there who I don't
think I've seen before name's Sylvia hex
she's the girl on the trailer that you
see screaming she gets more screen time
than Jared Leto in the movie yeah she's
really good she's a character too that
you're very fat fascinated by it's
curious what's going on underneath her
what I loved about this film is everyone
has something more going on underneath
then what is just being presented about
in dialog and on the surface there are
almost no incidental characters in the
main action of this movie and it's to
the film's credit across the board that
you know even characters that don't feel
super important when you meet them when
they get back later you're like wow you
really thought this out it makes sense
yeah good job this actress who I've only
seen the movie knock-knock I'm a good
guy I don't recall seeing her character
in the trailer maybe a brief moment here
there in the trailer I think yes as a
big purple hologram yes yeah yes it's
super brief she actually isn't in the
movie for a pretty good amount of the
film yeah and I don't want to give it
away even if I did it wouldn't be like
watch you spoil that I don't think you
get that feeling but it is a nice thing
in terms of what her character isn't and
the purpose she serves in the film yes
she plot brought in a plot line I was
not expecting yeah we cared about her I
cared about her hurry
yeah and that was one of the more
interesting like world buildi things
yeah going into too much detail her plot
line involves a new aspect of the Blade
Runner universe at least is yeah terms
of the first movie and
I found that very engrossing especially
for her how she plays off Ryan Gosling
that was the biggest I felt with this
film my heart was connected not to
everyone in this film but there's a
goodness like enough characters in there
for me to feel emotionally drawn to
which I really appreciated such a
anticipated sci-fi spectacle like this
and then of course
Harrison Ford who if you've never seen
any trailers good for you because Denis
already mentioned an interview that he's
not gonna be in the film for as long as
people probably think he is he's not the
main character he's not the main
supporting case he's more than a cam
he's important though yeah he's more
than it yeah he's more than a cameo it's
one of those things were like and I
don't think this is to spoil too much
it's like when you get the way the movie
unfolds you're like oh yeah it'll
probably take a while to see him but
when he gets here you know we probably
just skip past him or anything yeah it's
worth it yeah and if you're if you love
Deckard so much cuz he comes in pretty
late into this long-ass movie yeah and I
wasn't watching the movie going where
the hell is Harrison Ford yeah wasn't
thinking that I will give you that it
was so late into the film I thought he
was gonna show up on a mountain with a
hoodie yeah that's something - again -
the film's credit because I think you
were more engrossed than I was and I I
never found myself getting impatient
going when are all those orange scenes
coming like you can't really blame the
marketing too much because you're like
well yeah I mean doing a Blade Runner
sequel after so many years people are
gonna want to know for sure of Harrison
pours in it so you have to reveal some
of the scenes some moments of the scenes
he is important and he is necessary it's
not just like we go to throw in her
subordinate yeah yeah they do bother to
tie it in pretty intimately yeah - the
first movie yeah and I found this
Deckard more intriguing than the Deckard
we got in the first one weirdly I think
he's a little more to do he has lived
more life by this time and as the the
opening title card of the movie tells
you a lot has happened last time we saw
him so yeah when he finally shows up
there is a new sense of dimension -
Decker that comes partly from AIDS
also partly from the context we give
gathered over this whole movie character
gets to be a lot more emotional - yeah
which I appreciate it because that
causes me to care more about who Deckard
is and what he's been through and yes
like if you watch any of the interviews
with passing in for they're always
having a great time together if their
chemistry and interviews is not the same
thing in this movie no it's very serious
they work well with each other
do you play off each other really well
and also the script I thought this
script was so well done I thought from
beginning to end it is a movie that
comes completely full circle by the end
of the film the plot was intriguing in
the mystery element was really even even
though I had [ __ ] spoiled for me I was
still like maybe I'm lying
it was a joke because that's how strong
this script was I love the way all the
characters are written I love the way
the mystery element was my only thing
honestly after the experience of
watching it was just I thought
everything was was terrific for the most
part it just left me cold I guess at
least right now like I'm appreciating it
more now that movie you have to digest
yeah it's like we are literally shooting
this as we've gotten back from watching
it so you know this isn't my favorite
time to talk about a movie like this
that needs time to sink into ya brain I
never got fully swept up in it like I
was always aware I was kind of watching
this movie happen see III would
occasionally not be swept up in it
because I would be distracted by my own
angry feelings of happiness Boyle for me
moments before watching this movie it
could also be the hype and machine
because sometimes and we talked about
this earlier like sometimes you know a
couple times a year there will be a
movie that's such a big deal that the
first time I watch it it doesn't even
feel like I actually watched it if yeah
like some kind of dream I had I had
trouble connecting to it yeah I was
always impressed by stuff and I
connected to certain elements of it like
you know I thought Ryan Gosling was
terrific and I liked that character a
lot and I could kind of resonate with
that character there's just something
that kept me at an arm's distance for
really you know plugging in and enjoying
it I can understand that actually I
it's a lot going on in this movie for a
film that's like also takes its time
with its pacing it is still plenty to be
to be absorbing and it can be hard to
really see how you feel because a lot of
it requires intellectual thoughts and
processing information of what's going
on this seems like the kind of movie
that I might enjoy more in a rewatch
like my tongue just wants to say I love
it and not just because everyone's
saying I genuinely do feel like there's
enough in there for me to be like I love
the movie if you love it I would be
psyched for you and if somebody tells me
they're gonna see it I'd be like yeah go
see it but I'm not about to grab
somebody be like you've got to see Blade
Runner 2049 like that really well cuz
the enthusiasm isn't there yeah for me
right this minute yeah anyway you know
my enthusiasm to be like no no no people
need to know and it's weird cuz like
this movie specifically was and wasn't
what I was expecting kinda at the same
time that's the only complaint I could
really love you against it there's
nothing else food stands out yeah bottom
line everything on a technical scale is
really strong in this film and I did
thoroughly enjoy from beginning to end
more than the first Blade Runner and III
definitely say go and if you can go
watch it at a real IMAX screen because
it's not fully blown up in IMAX format
they did enhance they did enhance it
enough where it takes up more of the
screen and and you get through celerity
quality man alright guys that's our
review for Blade Runner
20:49 whoo did you see Blade Runner 2049
did you like it did you like it more
than the last Blade Runner do you think
the first Wade Runner is just a little
bit overrated come on I remember saying
that to you like not long ago Blade
Runner went from failure to cult hit two
losses one of the best sci-fi movies
ever and I think the next phase is it's
overrated well guys you can subscribe to
the real rejects please click that
notification Belka subscribe buttons
don't really work that John Humphrey on
Twitter and Instagram I'm at the greg
alba you could check out our patreon
become a patronage act today it's worth
it peeps and follow us on stardust
follow us first you know what to do